[Applause]
my mom got a little political attack
she just started [ __ ] on fox news
yeah that they because she's a
republican and she's like are they
because they called like arizona early
or something so she was like we don't
watch that in this house anymore like
she's real [ __ ] she is feeling down
there
is she on like one american news or
whatever well she's well yeah whatever
trump's going to come out with she's
[ __ ] she's she's full board she's
partying
they want to move to florida and [ __ ]
patreon she's like news network
oh yeah oh let's go so okay
now is that tricky what navigating that
with my mom yeah
now like i like when i go home a couple
of wines in here yeah
i don't i haven't been home since the
election obviously because like covenant
[ __ ] yeah
so it might be dicey but like also i
don't engage with her
about it really we'll have like we'll
have like an educated conversation you
know our parents used to say like i
don't talk politics
that generation that's all they well so
well what till facebook came around and
that's all they [ __ ] they're just
sharing all these bonuses
people in the burbs they don't got [ __ ]
to do they're sitting around [ __ ]
arguing over their [ __ ] while drinking
[ __ ]
white people i know but we go home and
we want to sit and relax with our family
and stuff like that then you have like
some cousin
that chimes in with it so yeah i think
that's why they're always yapping about
it down there
shouldn't talk about politics no maybe
facebook the reason why they do on faces
is because they can disconnect from it
right
so it's like if you're at dinner with
the whole fam and somebody brings it up
and you know it's just going to be like
this huge fight
it's not worth it but people come at it
from but they get the emotional
you know what i mean like they can't
separate you're in person you're online
so it's like they say something over the
dinner table that's like you could tell
would be all in caps
on facebook like a [ __ ] psycho you
know what i mean right it's like dude
[ __ ] relax i want to know about like
the
trump political dinner conversation
like do you have brothers or sisters or
anything yeah yeah are they also
conservative
uh tell me about the family fights
that's what yeah well like
especially when i go home and it's all
like my [ __ ] meathead uncles and
cousins and [ __ ] they're like ah there's
the democrat the new york democrat like
are you liberal uh i would uh no but
today
he's a chaos he's in the entertainment
yeah i mean liberal is defined on
twitter no i you know i'm not far left
insane liberal i am you know i call
balls and strikes is the way i like to
put it you know what i mean like he
doesn't tuck in his eagles jersey so
he's considered a liberal
yeah um
you know what i mean i know that you
desean jackson that
shirt tucked in mr fancy pants up there
in new york
you were chuck schumer huh you and
schumer yeah
you're supposed to duck to your blue
that's a nice shirt dude you're good to
go
tucking it in was the proper thing
like a [ __ ] gentleman dude you know
what i mean you're going to a christian
god you're gonna walk into a home depot
with no mask on you better have your
[ __ ] jersey
you know what i'm saying come [ __ ]
correct
oh my god right okay dude yes that's
great okay
so then you go you have these
conversations they think that you're
this like kind of liberal [ __ ] because
they exist in this facebook world where
if you're not a hundred percent on board
with trump then you are communist
yeah well it's also it's like they also
this is your family know that probably
yeah
trump supporters yeah girl who's on
twitter just like you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're related
to them we're not that crazy but like
i wouldn't be nuts like one of my
cousins would have married her kind of
you know what i mean she wouldn't be
bloodline but like
she would marry into the family yeah uh
pretty sexy though what did she say in
your dm she dm'd him yeah oh really
listen to the pod she's like yo my
friends are telling me that uh
that uh you guys were talking about me
on the pod i'd love to come on the pod
and talk about it brilliant
uh no no flavor oh [ __ ] damn you gonna
have her tina
let's see how the election pans out
maybe we'll do like the uh
maybe if trump concedes we'll do like
the first interview with her
oh that's pretty good yeah yeah yeah
yeah biden 2020 [ __ ]
okay but go on um yeah so it's just like
but it's also very and i think you know
this is
my two cents it's very the let me
clarify the question
i'm curious about here is you you are
not a stranger on facebook to your
mother
your mother knows who you are knows the
type of person you are type of human you
are
and i'm wondering if she can detach your
disagreement politically
from how she feels about you as a human
being
or is she so wrapped up in the politics
that that is
clouding her judgment of even her own
son no not at all not will she run you
over in her command
depends what protest uh no not at all
she's not like that
except like sometimes when we do we will
engage and i'm like you know what [ __ ] i
got nothing to do this afternoon like
let's [ __ ] roll up the sleeves and
get into it yeah yeah it's like
you know it'll be like you know the pro
wall or whatever and like i'm coming out
from like i'm like i think that's not a
good idea for humanity or like you know
like and she's like oh you [ __ ]
liberal i'm like you raised me to be a
nice person
sorry i don't want kids in cages you
bestowed that upon me as a child like
you know and so it's like that stuff and
then like it eventually goes all right
well let's just move on like why do we
never
solve anything yeah why do you think
that uh specifically with trump it's
become
so political like i didn't remember it
to be this
charged up in the past did you like was
your mom this chart up about bob dole
no no no no no well it's all i mean you
know it's probably a lot of things to go
into with social media it's
everybody's now thinks they have an
opinion and a brand or whatever like
this is what i post this is what i share
like everybody thinks they're a [ __ ]
corporation so they're getting more
feedback on their opinions than they
ever had in the past
but then it becomes a facebook makes it
an echo chamber or whatever you know
what i mean like
so it's like i'm only going to share
this [ __ ] wacko post that i know is
going to get a bunch of likes from these
wackos that
well where did that come from i think
people just got pushed you know they're
they got pushed to the back of the wall
a little bit and i think the left
you know forces it down their throat so
much that people like that will leak in
the middle
they see that now like oh well [ __ ] this
you know what i mean yeah it was just a
really bad perfect storm
of everybody not shutting the [ __ ] up
and then trump was the one guy that was
like you matter to me and then yeah then
he
he cultivated that very ingeniously yeah
yeah he took advantage of of a culture
war that he probably
assisted sure creating yeah but i do
think too like i don't know i'm looking
at it from my perspective as i'm a 34
year old
[ __ ] guy and it's like you do it is
proven that like as you get older you
tend to be more conservative
right like that's that's how it trends
right there was a i don't know who said
it i heard the the saying it's like
until you like hit an amount of money
where you'll always be okay and then you
become this like
charitable liberal you know like bill
sure bill gates was like the most
concerned he was a piece of [ __ ]
yeah yeah life and the second he became
the richest man he's like i should
probably give away a lot there's a whole
movie about how he [ __ ] steve jobs
and now he's giving away everything yeah
he's this sweetheart
so there is like a you know what does it
come full circle
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but keep going
um
i forget where i was oh you're talking
about as you get older you become more
concerned yeah so there's the saying of
like
if you if you show me a liberal
over he has no if you're if you show me
a liberal over 30
i'll show you an idiot or no if you show
me if you're under 30 and you're liberal
you don't have a heart and if you're
over 30 and you're a liberal you don't
[Laughter]
i know but like now we're like we're
talking about like like you know my
my parents are talking about money and
like wills and [ __ ] and now like i'm
looking at money and i'm like
ah pretty conservative guy now you know
what i mean like it's not so [ __ ] bad
why is the government gonna get money
off of them
yeah i'm like hey pay tax already i
gotta pay tax on it yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ]
well shout out to trump he upped it he
upped it by the way up to what he dumped
well he upped the allowed for like up to
like 11 million
or something you don't have to pay taxes
it is quite absurd though
he's doing some research but now for
real why why can someone explain the
death tax like why do you have to pay
money for your folks dying
because it's viewed as income that's the
way they do it they view it as it's an
income to you
it's not your money so no money can
change hands
up to fifteen thousand dollars a year
every year to person
that is interesting so you can you could
gift me fifteen thousand dollars a year
if you want to it's up to you completely
i'm not i thought it was ten has gone up
it's gone up it's fifteen thousand
dollars now a year you can gift anything
you know why
i know that it's ten is this garbage
shawshank redemption yeah exactly
oh yeah yeah yeah and the sopranos she
was trying to hide the money from tony
that she took out of the bird feeder
another food thing
[Laughter]
he was looking at that bird feeder like
god damn if i get my hands on that bird
feeder
you're going all political it's out of
my room
you